hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to well it's um it's not a
let's play it's a vlog
so that's cool jacob make this
make this intro more or less awkward
rotating dog mode rotating
rotating chica just stay right there be
my little bubbernut
and uh help me make this intro less
awkward hello everybody
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the vlog
i guess here's a dog i guess
okay all right then
okay bye pup go lay down okay so hello
it has been a while oh chica you're back
i'm not gonna pick you up again it's
okay you're gonna lay down go be good
she's right there so it's been a while
literally since the 20th of april till
about two days ago i've been traveling
uh and that's a long time it's
almost three weeks straight that i've
been traveling and it's been
making me slowly lose my mind and i've
been away from chica for a long long
time but it's cool
we're back now i did come back for like
a few days that's why i picked her up
and then
had to immediately say goodbye again
which was horrible but anyway so
it's been a lot of traveling and just to
go on this trip i had to pre-record like
30 oh like no wait i had to pre-record
like 50-something videos which is why
the order the videos have been coming
out have been a little strange
intermixed with current day stuff the
inner splice with old stuff
um so i apologize if it's been confusing
and inconsistent but i'm back now
chica stop breathing so loudly hold it
down
don't give me that look it's an adorable
look but it's not gonna work on me
even though it works on me all day every
time so anyway it's been a while and i
haven't been able to make a vlog or
reading your comments in a long time and
i was actually thinking about that uh
between
vlogs and reading your comments because
it used to be that i made a vlog every
monday just to talk with you guys and
then i tried to start making readier
comments every monday
uh because i like hearing from you guys
but then it became like a
debate between the two uh do i vlog or
do i do reading your comments
i want to talk to you guys but i also
want to hear you guys so it became like
this
conundrum of which one do i do on a
monday and
i reached the conclusion that i'm
probably just going to do both
uh it may not come out every week but i
do want to have the opportunity to talk
to you guys and then i also want to make
reading your comments because they're
really fun
and i like to make them entertaining for
you guys so expect
both i don't know if they're both going
to be on a monday maybe one's going to
be on monday later in the week but
just to be fair to you guys i'm gonna do
both so don't even worry about debating
between the two i just spat
something something shot out of my mouth
i have no idea what so all in all
i have a lot to tell you guys about uh
i'll try to keep it relatively short
pax was amazing i got to see my friends
again
obviously that was good uh bob wasn't
there because he is now
done with law school which is freaking
fantastic
because that means that hopefully he and
wayne uh maybe even jack
and some other guys will be able to
visit me here in la
which would be nice because the crushing
loneliness
is getting to me god damn it but
congratulations to him and it was really
fun to hang out with the other guys
while i was in pax uh boston uh and then
after that i went back to cincinnati for
a little bit and then
i took this awesome trip to new york
where i got to hang out with jack and
felix and a whole slew of other
youtubers
like a whole bunch and i could tell like
there's so many stories from being there
that i i could
fill in entire videos with just what
happened in new york
basically we were there just to uh
celebrate
being youtubers and it was a big thing
made by youtube to get
some of its quote-unquote top creators
and i'm only quoting that because i was
there
why the hell am i included in the top
creator bunch i have no idea
um but uh it was just cool to be all in
one place and be able to talk with each
other and
you know hang out and do activities and
listen to speakers
and then generally just have a good time
with each other and it was great because
i went last year to the same thing
it was the creator summit in new york
and it inspired me
and and that was the most important
thing that came out of it is that i was
very inspired because
last year early on in the year like i
had a rough time with
uh the breakup i had with the last
relationship and then
of course the various things that
happened with me in the hospital and
obviously daniel and so last year was
a combination of struggling times but
this creator summit reminded me
of why i did youtube and why i do
youtube and what it's like not just to
be a youtuber but also to be inspired
to push myself to be better and uh
that's something i touched on in the
last vlog
and it's something that still rings true
in my heart like uh this stuff that i do
here this stuff
uh the videos that i make are a source
of
creative uh it's an outlet for my
creativity
and it's a way that i can channel what i
want to make
for you guys to enjoy so i i always come
out of these events and i got to meet
some new people and i got to meet some
youtubers like
uh ethan from h3h3 and uh obviously i
get to see jontron again and a
whole bunch of other creators that i i
won't even try to remember the names of
uh but they all are really cool guys in
my mind
and what was i saying man i got
sidetracked i always
this always happens i get so sidetracked
all the time when i'm trying to talk
i've got a million thoughts racing
through my mind about what happened in
new york
and trying to touch all the subjects in
a succinct amount of time
and i instead of looking like a doofus
to summarize meeting these cool people
and other youtubers that i work with and
also getting back in touch with
me watching youtubers and being inspired
by them
just through them entertaining me and
that's not saying i have high standards
of entertainment i have very low
standards of entertainment but just
seeing all these cool creators in one
place
is really really motivational and it
helps me push forward in what i create
and it always reminds me of what i need
to do but as far as stories from there
i mentioned it in uh the last video that
i did but i'll show it to you guys again
rachel ray gave me this trophy
because i make an incredible margarita
and here's my secret to margherita's
success
is a margarita is already simplistic
and good and you don't need to add a lot
of zest to it
you just need to make one and then
garnish it because presentation is 50
of everything that's my only claim to
like
impressing rachel ray but i'm gonna
cherish this statue
because everyone that sees me with this
trophy
wonders why the hell i brought the
trophy to wherever i went
literally after i won this i took it to
every bar
and every restaurant and even the club
afterwards and i was dancing on the
dance floor all by myself because who
the hell would have danced with me
i'm the crazy guy with the taco trophy
but
they talked to me probably because of my
success
not who i was they didn't know who i was
which is probably for the best
i'm the crazy taco guy
and jack's team won the best flavored
taco so congratulations to them
he didn't do a whole lot he just picked
the ingredients don't read too much into
it
okay i'm gonna stop embarrassing myself
um so
just in general it's good to be back and
it's good to be able to make videos
again
on time not that they've been on time
but you know in a timely manner i've
been just very running out of videos
that i have to catch up today's my big
recording day where i catch up on
everything um oh and i almost forgot
i am going to be in a comic book which
is really weird i'm actually going to
have a whole comic
uh miniseries featured about me uh
involving uh other characters from uh
this company called
red giant uh they make a whole bunch of
comics and uh i
me and my brother both are associated
with this uh
company because we've been going to
comic-con san diego
every year for the past four or five
years with them
uh they've been very good to me and they
are actually making a comic about me
and here's the cover of one of them
and stuff so if you want to see this you
can actually get it through the link in
the description below
in fact uh the link is to a box that
will get you a
special limited edition foil cover of it
something like that
so there's a link in the description
below check it out if you'd like uh and
i'll be going to comic-con again this
year so if you're going
hey i'll probably see you there but the
next convention that i'm going to is
actually going to be
vidcon in june so i'll see you there as
well so
thank you everybody so much for being
patient with me thank you for
uh watching the stuff that i've made and
i apologize
if some of it was a bit repetitive
because i literally
ran out of time before i left and i've
been um
doing my best but now that i'm back i'm
going to be working with ryan and matt
again we're going to make some
sketches for you we're going to be
making some new stuff that'll surprise
you and
uh one of the big things that i want to
make very soon
is a music video like i really want to
make a music video for you guys because
that was something
that syndigo did and it's something that
i've always wanted to try so
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna sing in it
and we'll see how it goes so
thank you everybody so much for watching
i look forward to the videos that i'm
gonna be making because
i am incredibly inspired and i'm always
inspired by
what you guys say to me and what i see
from other creators
just the whole big community of youtube
and having it presented
in front of me is always an incredibly
inspiring thing so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye oh god the puberty